en tus clases de matemáticas elementales
muy probablemente conociste lo que es un
factor así por ejemplo voy a elegir un
número arbitrario el número 12
sabemos que el número 12 lo podemos
escribir como el producto de 2 por 6 2
por 6 es igual a 12 y dado que 12 es el
producto de 2 por 6 podemos decir que 2
es un factor de 12 y que 6 también es un
factor de 12 el producto de 2 por 6 es
igual a 12 inclusive podemos decir que
aquí tenemos 12 descompuesto en factores
usualmente la gente no lo maneja así
pero podemos pensarlo en esos términos
hemos separado 12 en dos factores que
podemos multiplicar quizá también
recuerdas el concepto de factorización
en números primos en la cual el número
se descompone en factores primos así en
este caso 6 lo podemos escribir como dos
por tres y tendríamos dos por dos por
tres es igual a 12 así es que en este
caso
esta es la factorización en números
primos de 12 estos de aquí son los
factores primos
factores
primos así es que la idea general este
concepto de factores se refiere a los
números que al multiplicarlos resultan
en el número original o si estamos
hablando de descomposición en factores
es como a partir del número original
obtenemos los factores que al
multiplicarlos resultan en dicho número
lo que voy a hacer ahora es generalizar
este concepto desde la perspectiva del
álgebra así si tenemos por ejemplo una
expresión como 2 + 4x podemos reescribir
esta expresión como producto de dos
números o producto de un número y una
expresión o producto de dos expresiones
bien aquí hay algo que quizás ya viste
que puedes escribir esta expresión como
2 que multiplica a 1 + 2x y podemos
verificar que efectivamente esto
corresponde a 2 + 4x podemos hacer el
producto podemos distribuir este 2 como
2 por 1 es igual a 2
+ 2 x 2 x + 4 x así es que esto que
hemos hecho aquí se denomina en términos
algebraicos como la factorización de la
expresión algo que también se denomina
descomponer la expresión en factores en
este caso podemos considerar que hemos
factor izado el 2 o también el 1 2 x al
final de cuentas hemos descompuesto esta
expresión en dos factores
hagamos un par de ejemplos más y luego
veamos cómo es que pude hacer esto
simplemente lo hicimos pero nunca te
expliqué cómo es que lo pudimos hacer
hagamos pues otro ejemplo supongamos que
tenemos 6 no voy a usar otro color mejor
supongamos que tenemos 6 x
más
6 x + 3
que va a ser aquí 6 x + 30 este es un
ejemplo interesante una manera de pensar
esto es cómo podemos describir estos
términos para encontrar sus factores
comunes este término de aquí
literalmente es 6 por x mientras que 30
ya sabemos que es divisible entre 6 así
es que esto es 6 por 5 30 lo puede
escribir como 6 por 5 ahora aquí podemos
ver que ambos términos tienen el 6 como
factor común de alguna manera estamos
aplicando la propiedad distributiva en
reversa pues en vez de multiplicar por 6
estamos dividiendo entre 6 cada término
así es que sacamos el 6 como factor en
este término y en este término de acá
con lo que tenemos 6 que multiplica a
primero es 6 que multiplica x + 6 que
multiplica a 5 hemos factorizar 26 x más
30 como 6 que multiplica a x más 5 y
esto lo puede checar con la propiedad
distributiva a distribuir el 6 tenemos
x 6 x 5 o 6 x 30 hagamos algo un poco
más interesante donde necesitemos
factorizar una fracción digamos que
tenemos el caso déjame hacer esto con un
nuevo color supongamos que tenemos un
medio
menos
tres medios de x cómo podemos factorizar
esta expresión como podemos extraer un
factor aquí aquí te invito a que le
pongas pausa el vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta te doy una ayuda trata de
factorizar un medio hagamos entonces eso
si queremos actualizar un medio podemos
escribir este primer término como un
medio por uno menos un medio que
multiplica a 3 x 3 medios de x es lo
mismo que 3x dividido entre 2 o un medio
x 3x y aquí ya vemos que podemos
factorizar un medio para obtener un
medio que multiplica a uno menos 3x otra
manera de ver esto es puedes darte
cuenta que aquí ambos términos aquí los
puedes dividir entre un medio ya lo
mejor eso resulta más confuso cuando
tienes que hacerlo con fracciones pero
esa es otra manera de verlo aquí en este
caso ambos términos los puedo dividir
entre un medio un medio dividido entre
un medio me da 1 mientras que 3 medios
entre un medio resulta en tres esa es
otra manera de verlo no sé si te
confunda más o te confunda menos sin
embargo lo que espero que haya quedado
claro es cómo se hace la factorización
de expresiones algebraicas voy a hacer
otro ejemplo un poco más abstracto si
tenemos a x + ay cómo podemos factorizar
esta expresión observamos que ambos
términos tienen como factor así es que
esto lo podemos escribir como a que
multiplica a x más bien y aquí diríamos
que hemos factor izado a lo cual podemos
verificar si realizamos aquí el producto
distribuyendo la a para obtener a x más
allí